Salah satu area di mana quantum computing bisa meningkatkan machine learning
adalah yang berkaitan dengan fungsi kernel atau
matriks kernel — yuk kita cari tahu apa itu
dan kenapa kita butuh itu. Untuk mulai, kita akan ingat-ingat lagi
tiga hal: kenapa dot product muncul dalam machine learning,
kenapa masalah machine learning melibatkan dimensi yang lebih tinggi,
dan apa itu fungsi kernel.
Ingat bahwa dot product atau inner product dari
vektor n-dimensi a
dan b dihitung dari perkalian besaran a
dengan besaran b dan kosinus theta, yaitu sudut
di antara keduanya. Ini setara dengan mengalikan
setiap komponen a dengan komponen yang bersesuaian dari
b, lalu dijumlahkan. Perlu dicatat, kalau vektornya
hampir ortogonal — misalnya ketika a
punya komponen nol di tempat b punya komponen besar —
dot product-nya kecil. Ini setara dengan
theta yang mendekati pi per dua.
Begitu juga, kalau a punya komponen negatif sementara b
punya komponen positif,
artinya kedua vektor menunjuk ke
arah yang hampir berlawanan
dan theta mendekati pi,
hasil dot product-nya bisa jadi
negatif. Terakhir, kalau a punya komponen besar di tempat b
juga punya komponen besar dengan tanda yang sama,
berarti vektornya hampir sejajar dan theta sekitar nol,
sehingga dot product-nya besar
dan positif. Jadi sangat masuk akal kalau dot product
bisa jadi ukuran kemiripan yang berguna
untuk data. Tapi tidak semua data n-dimensi
bisa dipisahkan dengan mudah pakai potongan berdimensi n minus
satu, seperti garis,
bidang, atau hiperplane. Kalau data tidak terpisah dengan baik
dalam n dimensi, kita bisa menanamkan titik-titik data
ke dimensi yang lebih tinggi, misalnya m dimensi, dengan m
lebih besar dari n. Ini disebut feature mapping,
sering dinotasikan sebagai x ke phi(x), di mana
phi(x) adalah pemetaan dari bilangan real n-dimensi ke
bilangan real m-dimensi.
Ini paling mudah dibayangkan kalau
kita melengkungkan data satu dimensi ke atas menjadi
dua dimensi, atau mengambil data dua dimensi
lalu menanamkannya ke dalam tiga dimensi.
Tapi pada kenyataannya, kita sering menanamkan data ke ruang dengan ribuan
bahkan jutaan dimensi.
Dot product vektor tiga dimensi dibanding dot product
vektor dua dimensi bukan perbedaan yang signifikan,
tapi dot product vektor berjuta dimensi
jadi benar-benar tidak bisa dikerjakan
untuk dataset yang besar.
Makanya orang-orang menemukan trik yang cerdas:
bagaimana kalau kita pakai proyeksi
ke dimensi yang lebih tinggi dengan bentuk yang sangat spesifik,
sehingga dot product dari vektor di
dimensi tinggi itu adalah fungsi sederhana dari
vektor berdimensi rendahnya? Artinya, kita cari pemetaan
dari data x ke phi(x) berdimensi tinggi
sedemikian rupa sehingga inner product di
feature space dinyatakan oleh sebuah
fungsi sederhana dalam data berdimensi rendah.
Fungsi k ini disebut fungsi kernel.
Idealnya, kita ingin fungsi kernel ini
merupakan fungsi dari inner product
berdimensi rendah itu sendiri. Itu akan memberi kita
yang terbaik dari dua dunia: feature space berdimensi sangat tinggi
tapi dengan inner product yang murah dan mudah dihitung.
Sekilas mungkin tidak
langsung terlihat bahwa ini memungkinkan. Mari kita lihat
satu contoh sederhana dalam dimensi yang sangat rendah.
Perhatikan feature mapping spesifik ini — ia memetakan
vektor tiga dimensi ke dalam
ruang sembilan dimensi. Ternyata,
inner product dari feature yang sudah dipetakan ke sembilan dimensi
cukup dinyatakan dengan inner product di ruang
3D aslinya, dipangkatkan dua. Jadi inner product
dari ruang yang sudah dipetakan pakai fungsi phi
akan butuh perhitungan masing-masing dari
sembilan koordinat untuk
vektor pertama, lalu sembilan untuk
vektor kedua, kemudian inner product-nya sendiri yang butuh
sembilan perkalian lagi, lalu dijumlahkan —
totalnya dua puluh delapan operasi.
Sedangkan fungsi kernel cukup butuh tiga perkalian
dan dua penjumlahan — hanya empat operasi saja.
Tadi itu untuk memetakan titik data tiga dimensi ke
feature space sembilan dimensi.
Mudah dibayangkan betapa menguntungkannya ini
untuk ruang yang jauh lebih besar.
Fungsi kernel biasanya merupakan fungsi kontinu
yang bisa diterapkan ke vektor mana pun dalam dataset kita.
Kita menggunakan fungsi kernel dengan mengambil
pasangan titik data dari dataset kita
sebagai argumennya. Menerapkan fungsi kernel ke
setiap pasangan titik data dalam dataset
menghasilkan matriks simetris yang disebut matriks kernel.
Jenis fungsi kernel yang dipakai bergantung pada
masalahnya. Jadi untuk merangkum:
menggambarkan kemiripan vektor dalam dataset kita
sering butuh inner product; inner product di
feature space berdimensi sangat tinggi jadi mahal biayanya,
makanya kita pakai feature mapping yang bersesuaian
dengan fungsi kernel khusus tertentu
yang membuat perhitungannya lebih efisien.
Tapi pembatasan pada fungsi kernel khusus ini
membatasi jenis pemetaan ke feature space yang bisa
dilakukan secara efisien. Hal ini
bisa mencegah kita memisahkan data dengan baik.
Andai saja ada cara lain...
Di sinilah quantum computing masuk.
Feature mapping berdimensi sangat tinggi yang bersesuaian
dengan fungsi kernel bisa dijalankan
di komputer kuantum. Dalam quantum kernel estimator,
matriks kernel k dihitung,
lalu dari sana algoritma machine learning klasik bisa
digunakan untuk menyelesaikannya. Satu titik data x1
dimuat dan dipetakan, lalu
x2 yang lain dimuat
dan dipetakan. Karena inner product dari dua state kuantum
berkaitan dengan probabilitas pengukuran,
kita bisa mengestimasi inner product dari dua titik data
yang sudah dipetakan dengan melakukan cukup banyak pengukuran pada
circuit yang dihasilkan. Dengan cara ini, circuit kita
bisa memberi tahu kita tentang inner product
di ruang berdimensi tinggi mana pun yang bisa dimodelkan circuit tersebut,
tanpa kita harus menghitung inner product atau fungsi kernel secara klasik.
Ada banyak cara untuk mengkustomisasi dan menyempurnakan metode-metode ini,
dan memang selalu ada metode baru yang diusulkan
dan diuji. Semoga
gambaran umum ini bermanfaat untuk memahami
kerangka penerapan quantum computing
dalam metode machine learning,
terutama metode machine learning
yang melibatkan fungsi kernel.